dieser ort steht für einen grauen eine
brutalität die alles bisherige dieses
krieges in der ukraine in den schatten
stellt hunderte zivilisten wurden
ermordet frauen vergewaltigt familien
ausgelöscht
russland spricht von einer inszenierung
durch die ukraine wenn butscher der
wendepunkt des krieges ist wie sieht
dann der wendepunkt in der reaktion
darauf aus europa bereitet jetzt ein
einfuhrstopp für kohle vor
kommissionspräsidentin von der leyen
will nach kiew reisen und bundeskanzler
scholz wie sieht seine antwort auf die
gräueltaten aus einsätzen über butscher
muss deutschland mehr tun unser thema in
der phoenix runde
phoenix runde
schönen guten abend ganz herzlich
willkommen aus berlin ich darf dir meine
gäste vorstellen ich freue mich dass
marina weisband zugeschaltet ist sie ist
deutsch ukrainische publizistin
engagiert bei den grünen in diesen
wochen eine stimme für die ukraine ihre
verwandten leben auch noch in keiner
guten abend und ich begrüße manfred
weber von der csu ist vorsitzender der
svp fraktion im europaparlament
herzliche grüße nach straßburg und hier
studio sind professor dr marcel fritsche
präsident des deutschen instituts für
wirtschaftsforschung und professor dr
nicole dieckerhoff direktorin des
leibniz-instituts friedens und
konfliktforschung frau weisband wenn man
diese schrecklichen nachrichten aus
butter hört die bilder dort sieht wie
geht es ihnen wenn sie das sehen wie
geht es ihren verwandten in der ukraine
was hat das verändert bewirkt
liefen märz den wir fühlen weil der
tiefen verstörungen die führen ist
glaube ich niemand vom ausmaß der
brutalität
wirklich überrascht der sich mit der
geschichte russlands und der geschichte
der ukraine auskennt wir wissen auch
schon aus den anderen besetzten dörfern
muss den anderen besetzten städten von
hinrichtungen von folterungen von
vergewaltigungen von frauen und kindern
und boccia ist
wenn symbol dessen
aber
es passiert schon seit einer weile und
es wird weiter passieren für mich ist es
nur hoffentlich ein zeichen in den
westen dass das was wir die ganze zeit
schreien helft uns so schnell wie
möglich mit allen mitteln die gehen die
vertretbar sind
da geht es immer noch jeden tag um
menschenleben gerettet werden was
konkret fordern sie denn dann jetzt vom
westen als reaktion gerade auf das was
da passiert ist
fordere so schnell wie möglich entweder
eine energie embargo oder eine lösung
dass wir das geld für die energie die
wir einkaufen auf ein treuhandkonto
überweisen und dieses treuhandkonto so
lange sperren bis es in waffenstillstand
gibt denn wir brauchen die sanktionen
nicht mittelfristig wir brauchen sie
nicht die langfristig wir müssen meiner
meinung nach nicht denken wie kommen wir
über den nächsten oder den übernächsten
winter sondern wir müssen so früh und so
hart alle wirtschaftlichen maßnahmen
aufziehen wie es nur geht wenn die
sprache der stärke ist die sprache die
putin versteht wir müssen das für ihn
unmöglich machen diesen krieg
weiterzuführen in seinem wort ist nicht
zu trauen und
europa gerade deutschland hat diese
macht wenn nutzen diese macht nicht wir
schauen zu und
damit werden wir alle leben müssen
schauen wir mal direkt gehen wir mal
direkt weiter nach europa also herrn
weber nach straßburg herr weber wenn wir
das wenn man es frau weisband sagt wir
müssen jetzt sofort viel härtere
sanktionen ergreifen auch das energie
embargo das entspricht ja auch einem dem
was sie schon selber fordern wie schnell
wird die eu jetzt reagieren auf das was
in butter passiert ist
zunächst bot den zivilisationsbruch den
wir nicht mehr möglich gehalten haben in
der europäischen union und das ist die
verantwortung von russland des muss man
russland auch putin als kriegsverbrecher
bezeichnet der vertriebenen gehört und
die konkreten antworten ich freue mich
zunächst einmal dass heute die
kommission den kohle
ausgesprochen hat das mandat den schritt
die nächsten schritt geht in der
eskalation bei den sanktionen meine
fraktion die europäische volkspartei und
morgen nach lage der dinge auch das
gesamte europäische parlament wird sich
dafür aussprechen auch bei öl an
sofortigen importstopp auszusprechen da
geht es dann um die ganz großen summen
öl ist der größte profitbringer für
vladimir putin das ist die forderung die
wir erheben werden aber ich möchte noch
darauf hinweisen dass wir die
energiediskussion sehr intensiv aktuell
in deutschland in europa führen aber für
seelands gehen für die ukraine sind zwei
sachen noch viel dringlicher nämlich die
erste frage er braucht jetzt frisches
geld um seinen start überhaupt am laufen
zu halten in wenigen nun wird die
staatspleite der ukraine vorstellen dass
highstreet ihre hilfe ist jetzt
notwendig und das zweite was notwendig
ist das absolut dringlichste ist waffen
waffen waffen wir haben zehn soldaten in
der ukraine aber nur eine waffe ein
gewehr derzeit 14 soldaten das ist die
lage in der wir uns dort befinden viele
sind bereit viel anzukämpfen aber haben
wir die notwendige ausstattung und
deswegen ist die aller vordringlichste
aufgabe waffen zu liefern und da ist
europa leider gottes nicht bei den
ersten dabei die briten sind stark und
die amerikaner sind auch hilfreich wie
europäer die europäische union
mitgliedstaaten sind leider gottes nicht
an vorderster front deswegen dürfen wir
das angesichts der energiediskussion
ganz übersehen dass das die eigentlichen
zentralen botschaften jetzt kurzfristig
sind um der ukraine zu helfen okay also
waffen mehr geld und energie bleiben wir
mal eben bei der energie weil das jetzt
auch heute haben wir beschlossen wurde
kohle stopp aber im wert von vier
milliarden euro wenn ich es richtig
verstanden fritzsche welche auswirkungen
hat das auf uns
jetzt dass im ba gegenüber kohle hat
wahrscheinlich keine wirklich großen
auswirkungen das ist einfach zu wichtig
öl und vor allem die abhängigkeit von
gas das lässt sich nicht ersetzen also
kohle könnten sie zum teil durch
einheimische kohle aus deutschland aus
anderen europäischen ländern relativ
schnell ersetzen
was nicht möglich ist das gas also das
was bisher passiert ist an
wirtschaftlichen sanktionen
trifft europa und deutschland
wirtschaftlich nicht sehr hart also die
finanzsanktionen russische banken
abzuschneiden das trifft hauptsächlich
russland aber man sieht eben auch dass
russland durchaus auch
sanktionsmöglichkeiten auf ihrer seite
haben sie liefern beispielsweise weniger
düngemittel weniger weizen wenige andere
rohstoffe und energie die diskussion
vergessen wir auch dass auch diese
rohstoffe wichtig sind palladium
wichtige dinge für katalysatoren für für
andere dinge hat russland mit 45 prozent
fast die hälfte des weltsports also das
problem ist der westen für europäer sind
erpressbar und haben uns den letzten
zehn jahren von russland erpressbar
gemacht worden
gemacht nicht auch zum teil aus eigener
entscheidung heraus dass wir eben gesagt
haben wir wollen kohle atomkraft
abschalten erneuerbare energien sind
schnell genug ausgeweitet worden und wir
haben es sehen ins auges in eine höhere
abhängigkeit von russland begeben und
wenn man das jetzt sieht diese ja dieses
entsetzen was wir alle haben über roger
würden sie sagen das ist jetzt so ein
wendepunkt wo man eigentlich alle
wirtschaftlichen interessen hinten
anstellen muss
als wirtschaft wissenschaft würde ich
sagen es gibt fälle bei denen die
wirtschaft nicht relevant ist sondern wo
andere dinge relevanter sind und
moralischen politisch bin ich natürlich
voll und ganz dafür zu sagen man muss
diesen schritt gehen meine befürchtung
ist dass die politik auch gerade in
deutschland den menschen keinen reinen
wein einschenkt die mehrheit der
bevölkerung sagt ja wir wollen ein
embargo und zwar ein volles embargo auch
bei gas und öl auf der anderen seite
sagt die mehrheit der bevölkerung aber
ein tempolimit auf der autobahn oder
einen autofreien sonntag also wir wollen
keine einsprachen da ist die
inkonsistenz der wirtschaftliche preis
eines embargos wird hoch sein die
politik muss die menschen darauf
vorbereiten und das geschieht im
augenblick nicht das ist die kritik also
gar nicht zu sagen denn bagus falsch
sondern einfach zu sagen wenn man diesen
schritt muss man die menschen darauf
vorbereiten und das ist bisher nicht
passiert
frage auf was ist ihre reaktion darauf
wenn man das sieht was dort passiert ist
ist das überhaupt noch möglich dass man
sagt man glaubt noch an verhandlungen
man glaubt noch an einem wii gibt es
überhaupt noch einen weg raus jetzt oder
gibt es nur noch den weg den herr weber
gesagt hat mehr waffen waffen dass die
ukraine eben militärisch dann irgendwann
gegen russland dann siegt also ich
glaube das ist teil der antwort und das
sehen wir auch schon also durch die
bilder die jetzt noch mal von butscher
gekommen sind ist die bereitschaft
nochmal gestiegen schwerere waffen
andere arten von waffensystemen zu
liefern da werden wir viel sehen mit
blick auf die verhandlungen muss man
schon deutlich sagen dass auch vor den
bildern die wir jetzt gesehen haben die
keine so hohe aussicht auf erfolg hatten
und es lag unter anderem frau weiß man
hat das schon ganz schön gesagt daran
dass putins wort so wenig wert ist also
sozusagen die vertrauenswürdigkeit
russlands einfach ziemlich am boden
liegt nicht mehr wir haben die
ankündigung in den verhandlungen
russland hat gesagt dass sie ziehen sich
aus dem westen und aus der region kiew
zurück man wolle sozusagen ein zeichen
des vertrauens setzen und das ergebnis
des ganzen ist eine reorganisation der
truppen und die konzentration auf den
osten und damit zerstört man natürlich
vertrauen in friedensverhandlungen
butter und die gräueltaten die jetzt
dort aufgetaucht sind die ich auch wenig
überraschend finde leider aber die jetzt
eben sozusagen vor der
weltöffentlichkeit noch einmal dargelegt
worden sind machen das nicht besser
sondern verschlimmern die lage eher noch
aber ich glaube auch momentan geht es
gar nicht so sehr direkt um ein
verhandlungsergebnis sondern was
russland gerade probiert mit der
konzentration auf den osten ist im
grunde genommen aus den verhandlungen
rauszukommen indem man nämlich fakten
schafft wenn es russland gelingen sollte
den don was abzutrennen mit dem land
zugang zur krim dann könnten sie das
befestigen und erst mal so zu sagen mit
diesem ergebnis ganz ohne verhandlungen
leben zumindest können sie versuchen das
zu verteidigen das könnte sozusagen das
ziel sein dass sich hier mittelfristig
ergibt die frau weiß man heute hat slow
diemelsee lenski hat vor dem
un-sicherheitsrat gesprochen mit welcher
hoffnung haben sie das gesehen diese
rede hat auch die furchtbaren bilder von
butter dort gezeigt haben sie noch
setzen sie noch eine hoffnung auf die
uno
nein also von morgen sichern brauchen
wir da sicherlich durch die ständige
mitgliedschaft russlands einfach nicht
viel zu erwarten und also das instrument
ist einfach zahnlos in dem moment wo
einer der fünf ständigen vertreter
selbst der aggressor ist und
entsprechend jede resolution durch ein
veto verhindern kann ich glaube auch das
ist in erster linie
das einzige was hier funktioniert ist
wirklich stärke zu zeigen im sinne
ökonomischer stärke im sinne der wehr
fähigkeit der ukraine im sinne des
anlegens des preises dieses krieges
und dann hoffe ich auf eine sache
nämlich
russland verzeiht historisch nicht
wirklich gerne verlorene kriege also
wenn russische herrschaft kriege
verloren hatten dann folgte häufig eine
revolution was übrigens nicht der fall
war wenn es der bevölkerung materiell
schlecht gehen also aus hunger
entstanden wenig johnen aber nach
verlorenen kriegen geben meistens schon
der einzige garant
längerfristigen frieden in europa ist
tatsächlich ein regime wechsel in
russland aber glauben sie daran eine
das hängt auch sehr von uns ab das hängt
davon ab ob wir verstehen worum es geht
ich habe das gefühl viele reden über die
energie sanktionen über das senden von
waffen die ukraine als ginge es darum
nur den menschen in der ukraine zu
helfen ich sage das nur in
anführungszeichen den menschen in der
ukraine zu helfen ist extrem wichtig da
geht es um leben ja aber solange das
system putin fortbesteht man sollte eher
erfolge in der ukraine haben dann wird
er ja den krieg weiter führen er wird
dann den krieg nach moldawien bringen er
wird den krieg nach georgien bringen
dann werden grüne männchen in polen und
in den baltischen staaten stehen die
angeblich nicht zu russland gehören dann
wird es cyber angriffe auf polnische
infrastruktur geben die nato wird sich
streiten ob das dann schon eine
kriegshandlung ist sie würde sagen es
ist keine kriegshandlung weil man nicht
regieren möchte dieser ständige krieg
der damit in europa herrscht wird unsere
wirtschaft weit mehr treffen als
kurzfristige harte und konzentrierte
aktion ist jetzt können deswegen müssen
wir jetzt die situation in der wir sind
nutzen um möglichst einhalt zu gebieten
aber das hätte man doch dann wirklich
vor wochen machen müssen oder wenn man
jetzt dem das ist doch das was sie dann
auch wirklich schon seit wochen sagen
sie das ja das wusste jedoch auch
unglaublich frustrierend
weil es ist ja immer nur eine reaktion
auf dann noch schlimmere taten
wir reagieren das ist schlecht weil wir
haben es tatsächlich mit international
organisiertem autoritarismus zu tun es
ist ja nicht nur putin es sind auch alle
internationalen autoritären herrscher
die ihm den rücken stärken die die
sanktionen aufweichen füreinander die
freundschaft zueinander zeigen und wir
werden
2024 womöglich ein präsident tram
wiedersehen
europa und demokratische staaten
generell sind ständigen langsamen
reagieren um vorauszuschauen
augenblicke zu bleiben wenn man dabei
würde ich ganz gern anderen an weber
geben hierbei das ist das ist ja genau
der eindruck den viele menschen haben
dass man sagt man reagiert ist es der
ist mario pohl darüber sind wir entsetzt
sind für entsetzt über buddha wir wissen
nicht was noch alles kommt warum
reagieren wir immer nur oder reagiert
die eu und auch deutschland dann noch
nur und geht zeigt vorher nicht eine
andere stärke
ich persönlich bin genauso ungeduldig
wie die frau weiß band wenn es um diese
beschlüsse geht aber klar ist den den
großen tanker europäische union mit 27
staaten die einstimmigkeit die wir haben
zu bewegen ist keine einfache sache und
dass wir bei den bisherigen sanktions
paketen einstimmige beschlüsse gefasst
haben und die gemeinsam umgesetzt haben
dass die weltgemeinschaft so
zusammengerückt ist wie sie bei den
neuen resolutionen zu sagen gerückt ist
ist eine historische leistung die pakete
die jetzt auf den weg gebracht worden
sind hat es in dem ausmaß so noch nie
gegeben dass wir beispielsweise die
rücklagen der staatsbank der zentralbahn
kinder in russland eingefroren haben das
hat so in der form gegenüber einem
großen land noch nie gegeben insofern
möchte ich das nicht kleinreden aber
auch ich bin ungeduldig auch ich würde
mir weitere schritte wünschen und ich
möchte das auch im hinblick auf unsere
deutsche diskussion zuspitzen wir müssen
uns als deutsche schon auch bewusst
werden das letzte mal aus kiew
bombardiert worden des wartens deutsche
soldaten das ist gott sei dank lang
zurück aber es war es waren deutsche
soldaten und deswegen finde ich hat
unser lander besondere verantwortung in
diesem konflikt nämlich an der seite von
denen zu stehen die für freiheit und
demokratie eintreten die so leben wollen
wie wir leben und ich sage es deshalb
weil natürlich die berliner
bundesregierung in den letzten wochen
vor allem auf europäischer ebene im
bremserhäuschen gesessen ist wir hatten
bis dahin zwei lange diskussionen
darüber und dann kam erst unter anderem
von den sozialdemokraten das nein wir
hatten bei swift lange debatten und erst
über das wochenende aus der
internationale druck so groß war war die
bundesregierung bereit bei swift auch
nachzugeben bei energie haben wir jetzt
ähnliche debatten lage leider gottes er
in berlin gebremst wird und nicht in
europa gebremst wird und ich finde es
schade und es vorsichtig zu formulieren
ich finde schade eigentlich müsste
europa jetzt deutschland vorangehen aus
dieser geschichtlichen verantwortung
heraus aber die geschehen darauf führen
gemeinsam mit manuel makro und das
findet leider gottes zu wenig statt ich
möchte mehr einreden was passiert ist
bitte nicht falsch verstehen aber ich
habe es zu wenig sie bloß in der
engagement gerade von der
bundesregierung ok frau darauf wie
wichtig wäre das wäre das eine
möglichkeit dass man sagt in deutschland
hat ja auch aus einer historischen
verantwortung gegenüber russland
natürlich gedacht es ist gut wenn wir
russland als partner nehmen das war ja
auch ein grund unsere historische schuld
die wir nicht nur gegenüber der ukraine
haben sondern auch gegenüber russland
das macht es ja noch mal extra
kompliziert also wie muss sich
deutschland da jetzt aufstellen und
würden sie dem zustimmen was herr weber
sagt das ist immer zu langsamer also zum
letzten jahr das würde ich schon sagen
dass es tatsächlich so ist dass die
bundesregierung häufig der bremser ist
und häufig sozusagen sich erst ganz
zuletzt entscheidet und es wäre schön
vor allem wenn es schon absehbar ist
dass bestimmte sanktionen kommen werden
wenn die bundesregierung einmal
sozusagen nach vorne gehen würde und
nicht warten würde sozusagen das
schlusslicht der letzte macht das licht
aus das fände ich schon ganz
hervorragendes wird auch jetzt beim
energie boykott werden wir das wieder
erleben ich bin gar nicht unbedingt
dafür dass für einen vollständigen gas
boykott haben ich glaube tatsächlich
dass wir uns dafür mehr zeit nehmen
müssen um ihn auch abzufedern und da
hilft es auch nicht dass wir so zeigen
die bevölkerung informieren das hat
einfach sozusagen insgesamt für die
wirtschaft so harte folgen dass wir
glaube ich noch ein bisschen zeit
brauchen es abzufedern aber was ist
jetzt aber auch schon paparazzi scola
angeht aber er wird ja auch vorbereitet
also ich meine das muss man doch ganz
klar sehen wir reden hier über
sanktionen die eigentlich hinter den
kulissen ja vorbereitet werden es geht
eben nicht so schnell wir müssen ja
ausweichmöglichkeiten finden und da
passiert glaube ich ganz viel und da ihr
sozusagen gestaffelt vorzugehen jetzt
über kohle und öl zu reden das finde ich
vollständig vernünftig wäre auch ein
punkt noch mal wichtig ich finde es
langsam unproduktiv immer über die
besondere historische verantwortung zu
reden wir haben eine aktuelle politische
verantwortung für das was in der ukraine
passiert weil es eben nicht allein nur
die ukraine betrifft sondern im grunde
genommen die sicherheit und die
zukünftige ordnung auf dem europäischen
kontinent und damit auch eine ordnung
für oder eine verantwortung für diese
zukünftige ordnung das sollte uns
hinreichend motivieren dafür zu sorgen
dass putin diesen krieg nicht gewinnen
so ist ganz stolz hat gesagt als
reaktion auf die gräueltaten in
wohlstand wir werden im kreise der
verbündeten in den nächsten tagen
weitere maßnahmen beschließen der
freistaat das klingt extrem trocken und
ist dass die führungs ist das ein
ausweis der führungsrolle die
deutschland eigentlich zusteht
das muss man ja auch sagen es ist jetzt
nicht so dass deutschland in europa
isoliert ist sondern es gibt jedoch auch
eine ganze reihe anderer länder wie
österreich wie manche
zentraleuropäischen länder auch wie
italien die eine ähnlich hohe
abhängigkeit haben für die briten
amerikaner ist relativ leicht zu sagen
macht mal ein embargo weil die aber den
haben auch gesagt sie sind dafür mehr
sie sind sie öffnen sich langsam aber
italien hängt natürlich auch extrem
stark von gas lieferungen ab meine sorge
oder mein ich denke schon das ist klug
ist wenn man sich mal die geschichte von
ökonomischen sanktionen anschaut das ist
sehr gut auch immer was in petto zu
haben zu sagen auf eine antwort kommt
eine reaktion und man kann reagieren und
also nicht sofort das ganze programm
zunächst wurde das ganze programm man
muss auch sagen haben wir eben auch in
der runde angesprochen die sanktionen
über die finanzsanktionen das ist schon
ein sehr scharfes schwert und die
russische wirtschaft wird in diesem jahr
15 20 prozent schrumpfen also es wird
dort massenarbeitslosigkeit geben es
gibt inflationsraten von 20 30 prozent
leider ist es so dass nicht die elite
leitet sondern eben die menschen die
einfachen menschen die an menschen die
keine verantwortung für diesen krieg
tragen also ich glaube schon das ist
gute sich vorzubereiten
ich glaube da würde ich mir mehr
ehrlichkeit wünschen denn eigentlich
müsste man jetzt anfangen wenn man
solche sanktionen umsetzen will also
sprich die gasspeicher sind im
augenblick zu 25 prozent gefüllt die
müsste man so schnell wie möglich so
stark wie es geht füllen dass man eben
puffer hat und glaube ich auch wenn man
solche strategie hat muss man eben dass
auch ganzheitlich denken meine große
sorge im augenblick ist china solange
russland umgehungsmöglichkeiten hat und
auch über china sind die sanktionen nur
halb so scharf und halten so effektiv
wie sie sein können also auch da muss
man strategisch denken
eben zu sagen wir tun europäer wir
wollen harte sanktionen aber wir wollen
eben auch gerade china und auch indien
müssten sich beteiligen damit es
wirklich nach effektiv ist und was würde
das dann für unsere gesellschaft
bedeuten sie sagen gas das kriegen wir
also das wäre weil viele bürger sagen ja
wir sind bereit ein opfer zu bringen
aber ganz konkret würde das zu einer
rezession führen was würde das bedeuten
wenn es einen barcode gebe oder einen
lieferstopp russlands das gibt es ja
auch eine möglichkeit das ist nicht nur
so dass wir entscheiden sondern russen
putin kann selber das entscheiden und
ich befürchte er wird das könnte das
machen und zwar im september oktober
wenn der winter uns vor bestehe für
bevorsteht wenn es einen barcode gäbe
dann würden wir wahrscheinlich eine
tiefe rezession fallen wo wir im
augenblick sind ist dass wir von dem was
bisher passiert ist mit ungefähr zwei
prozentpunkten weniger
wirtschaftsleistung rechnen das ist
jetzt nicht dramatisch das haben wir
nicht mal vier prozent wachstum in
diesem jahr sondern vielleicht nur noch
zwei prozent also wir sind nicht
besonders hart getroffen aber ein
embargo würde mit hoher
wahrscheinlichkeit die deutsche
wirtschaft in einer rezession treiben
heißt wir hätten höhere arbeitslosigkeit
wir müssen uns darauf einrichten dass
energieintensive branchen wie die chemie
branche zeitweise zu machen müsste und
wir müssten uns mit inflationsraten
jenseits von 10% vorbereiten und es
trifft also diese krise ist höchst
unsozial was eben menschen mit geringen
einkommen über energiepreise aber auch
nahrungsmittelpreise besonders hart
trifft und auch da wenn man sich jetzt
das paket der bundesregierung anschaut
sind wir eben nicht besonders gut
vorbereitet herr weber wie würden sie
sehen halten wir das aus als
gesellschaft auch in europa wenn durch
ein solches embargo unsere wirtschaft
stark leidet
ich habe eine position ist eben öl und
kohle jetzt und gas so schnell wie
möglich um
einen verantwortbaren weg zu gehen das
heißt so schnell wie möglich noch meine
position welche welche zeitraum wäre das
das liegt das liegt an der fragestellung
wie schnell wir kompensieren können wie
schnell auf die europäische solidarität
funktioniert die gasspeicher in europa
gemeinsam bewirtschaftet werden wir
müssen uns gegenseitig aushelfen in
europa damit dass alles funktioniert
also insofern ist doch einiges zu tun
über den sommer hinweg und auch die
frage ob ihr international mit gas
bekommen und ob das angelandet werden
kann das sind die praktischen fragen die
jetzt anstehen das deshalb einen harten
weg gehen bleibt dabei ist wirklich
harte schwert weil da geht es um viele
milliarden die input dem system entzogen
werden und bei gas auch verantwortbar
vorzugehen aber ich möchte ausdrücklich
den gedanken hinein unterstreichen weil
unsere ganzen sanktionen die wir hier
diskutieren werden dann ins leere laufen
wenn es uns international nicht gelingt
die geschlossenheit zu organisieren am
freitag letzter woche fand in brüssel
der eu china gipfel statt und die
aussagen von präsident sie waren da
leider gottes nicht ermutigend er hat
viele aus der russischen propaganda
übernommen und hat uns europäer
stückweit vorgeworfen dass wir mit
schuld an diesem krieg sind es sind sehr
beunruhigende nachrichten die wir der sp
kind bekommen und das muss uns auch
nachdenklich stimmen und weil ich sage
wir werden auch gegenüber china es geht
nicht nur um russland sondern auch
gegenüber china in die
grundsatzdiskussion gehen wir mit
autokratien umgehen muss sie jetzt im
herbst als präsident chinas verlängert
wird dann wird er auf lebenszeit im amt
sein dann haben wir ähnliche gemengen
lage wie wir sie heute mit putin haben
das ist alles sehr bedrückend und wird
uns deutschen dazu zwingen uns europäern
dazu zwingen auch unser
wirtschaftsmodell auf den prüfstand zu
stellen weil die letzten 30 jahre haben
wir wohlstand genießen dürfen weil wir
billige energie und rohstoffe hatten und
weil die welt unsere produkte abgekauft
hat das wird zu ende gehen wir stehen in
der wendezeit und das müssen wir ganz
ehrlich als politiker den menschen sagen
dass sich viele fundamental verändern
wird und was hast du unsere aufgabe ist
es dann auch zu zeigen wie denn die
lösung aussieht der sendet nur das
geschrieben des problems sondern wir
müssen dann auch lösung beschlossen das
heißt aber auch dass wir uns ja das
klingt alles nach und ja einer
längerfristigen perspektive wo wir uns
ändern wir sind frau weiß man wenn sie
das so hören das ist ja dann damit nimmt
man ja sie haben vorhin gesagt wir
müssen ganz schnell etwas machen also
das heißt ja nicht dass wir damit
schnell den krieg beenden
nein und das ist dass sie haben wir
tatsächlich frage vorweg genommen die
ich sehr gerne auch an herrn fischer
gerne stellen würde nämlich was haben
wir eigentlich davon dass russland eine
massenarbeitslosigkeit hat oder der
bundeskanzler hat neulich gesagt unsere
sanktionen
nehmen die entwicklung die ökonomische
entwicklung in russland was haben wir
doch schon warum wollen wir ein großes
land dass ökonomisch langfristig
gebeutelt wird es geht doch darum
also für mich zumindest geht es darum
diesen krieg zu beenden
es scheint mir nicht dass die
diskussionen um die sanktionen beraten
darauf ausgerichtet sind
ich weiß nicht warum es besser ist dass
wir mit katar verhandelt über fossile
energien als mit russland
ich denke dass
wir tatsächlich
konzentriert
treffen müssen um putin zu handlungen zu
zwingen dass wir ihm voraus sein müssen
aber das gebe dafür macht man die
sanktionen das ist doch gerade dadurch
würde halt gerne verstehen warum müssen
wir sanktionen zurückhalten um reagieren
zu können auf was sollen wir noch
reagieren was muss mehr passieren wie
viele familien müssen ausgelöscht werden
wie viele städte müssen zerstört werden
welche dinge halten wird zurück warum
also
frau weiß man ich bin komplett bei ihnen
wenn die sanktionen wenn man sich die
sanktionen helfen den krieg zu beenden
denke ich muss dass das oberste ziel
sein aber
dadurch dass der westen die nato gesagte
begreifen militärisch nicht ein sondern
wirtschaftliche sanktionen putin ist
vorbereitet er hat große reserven das
geld
machen knallharten gas-embargo glauben
sie dass das dass das zum beispiel so
etwas wie im busch davor verhindert
hätte botschaft ich bin bin
wirtschaftswissenschaftler ich würde das
sehr stark bezweifeln die waffen die in
russland im krieg eingesetzt werden
werden ausschließlich in russland
hergestellt das ist nicht so dass er
jetzt nimmt sagt hier das sind jetzt die
einnahmen von den gasexporten nach
deutschland das nehme ich jetzt um
waffen aus indien oder china zu kaufen
ich glaube das funktioniert im
augenblick nicht ich glaube also wenn
man sich noch mal wird ein historisch
die die art und weise anschaut wie
wirtschaftliche sanktionen funktionieren
ist fast immer darüber dass es eben die
menschen am stärksten trifft und der
druck von der bevölkerung auf die eigene
regierung zunimmt das ist bevölkerung
wird aber im moment noch nicht mal
richtig informiert über diesen krieg die
weiß doch gar nicht also es kann ja dann
einfach nicht funktionieren das ist die
sorge dass das das muss man eben ganz
ehrlich sich anschauen und sagen
wenn man sagt wenn man sanktionen macht
dann bitte oder idealerweise so dass sie
möglichst effektiv sind das was man ja
weiß man beschreibt also im prinzip den
krieg möglichst schnell zu beenden aber
wirtschaftliche sanktionen zu glauben je
härter wie sie machen das ist eine
garantie dafür dass der krieg beendet
wird diese garantie haben wir eben nicht
mehr leiten die erfahrungen die wir mit
sanktionen auch haben sind dass sie
nicht direkt wirken also sie sind nicht
wie ein lichtschalter den wir betätigen
können und dann ist einem regime so die
luft abgedreht dass es nicht mehr
handeln kann und sich zurückziehen muss
aus einem konflikt sondern sanktionen
funktionieren tatsächlich überzeugt sie
bauen sich normalerweise auf und so ist
es auch mit diesen sanktionen
es geht nicht darum dass wir eine
massenarbeitslosigkeit in russland haben
es geht darum dass über zeit sich die
russische wirtschaft nicht mehr
modernisieren kann dass sie dann auch
tatsächlich in der kriegswirtschaft
enorme probleme gerät weil sie
beispielsweise panzer und ähnliches
nicht mehr bauen kann um all das geht es
auch wenn wir vor vier wochen schon den
gashahn zugedreht hätten wären wir jetzt
in der gleichen situation
wir sind ganz häufig enorm optimistisch
wie schnell der der das zu drehen eines
geldhahn als andere dazu bringen soll
ihr verhalten zu verändern wir haben
ganz viele historische erfahrungen
gesammelt das regime unglaublich lange
selbst damit noch durchhalten können es
geht aber darum dass wir jetzt anfangen
müssen um überhaupt diese wirkung über
zeit zu erreichen und der regime wechsel
klingt immer so verlockend und das
verstehe ich auch aber man muss sich
eines klar machen bei einem regime
wechsel wissen wir nicht wer anstelle
von putin das sind normalerweise zeiten
in denen es eher zu mehr gewalt kommen
zu eskalation und nicht phasen eines
ruhigen macht übergangs das heißt besser
wäre es wenn tatsächliche überzeit wer
einen machtwechsel erleben schlicht und
einfach weil nach und nach putin
sozusagen die gefolgschaft verliert aber
mich im sinne wenn das so lange dauert
also bis sanktionen wirken ist denn dann
stärkere waffenlieferung schwerere
waffen ist dass dann die einen die
antwort die wir brauchen um jetzt den
krieg zu beenden es ist im grunde
genommen von anfang an ja eine
zweigeteilte strategie gewesen auf der
einen seite waffenlieferung um die
ukraine zu befähigen sich zu verteidigen
gegen diese aggression flankiert durch
in der tat historisch tatsächlich
unvergleichlich harte und schnell
zustande gekommene sanktionen und das
sind sie nach wie vor auch wenn wir noch
keine energie embargo haben das hier
sind sehr sehr harte sanktion aber herr
vater hat natürlich recht großmächte und
das wissen wir auch aus der forschung
sanktionen gegen großmächte sind
generell weniger wirksam warum weil
großmächte viel mehr möglichkeiten haben
sanktionen zu umgehen das heißt wir
müssen jetzt sehr genau darauf achten
was russland eigentlich mit china für
vereinbarung trifft und auch mit indien
der russische außenminister war gerade
in indien und der ging es um ihren
einfluss auf china
ausüben ich würde gerne erstmal einfach
zu den waffen noch mal kommen wenn mir
gesagt aber die sagen zu einer märz
schon länger geredet er weber sie haben
ja eben schon gesagt sie sind dafür dass
wir mehr waffen jetzt liefern es gab
kritik an der bundes
verteidigungsministerin christine
lambrecht ihr parteikollege markus söder
hat sogar den rücktritt gefordert sehen
sie das ähnlich er sprach von einer
blamage für deutschland wenn er mit der
verteidigungsministerien
das dass wir deutschland kein
ruhmesblatt war glaube ich ist
offensichtlich sie erinnern sich an die
anfängliche debatte über die helme die
wir geliefert haben in einer
notsituation eine extremsituation
aber ich würde schon sagen dass die
dynamik der letzten tage jetzt positiv
wie es beispielsweise die freigabe der
alten nva waffen die wir in der
tschechischen republik jetzt hatten vor
allem die panzer die dort freigegeben
sind sind hilfreich die ukraine sagen
unser europäern ja bitte liefert uns
ehemalige sowjet waffen weil die auch
bei uns viele bedienen können weil viele
dort ausgebildet sind also wenn wir
modernste westliche waffen liefern
würden könnten die vielleicht gar nicht
so zum einsatz kommen deshalb muss man
auch dass auch rücksicht nehmen was uns
die ukraine jetzt am weg geben aber es
kann noch viel mehr gemacht werden und
die um die zahl nochmal im vergleich zu
setzen die europäische union hat
erstmals und diese historische schritte
jetzt gelder bereitstellt um waffen zu
kaufen wir europäer die europäische
union dieses großen zweimal 500
millionen euro die wir jetzt der ukraine
bereitstellen zweimal 500 millionen für
waffenkauf und auf der anderen seite
haben wir mehr als 770 millionen die wir
jeden tag überweisen an
energielieferungen deshalb ist diese
debatte schon wichtig und substanziell
und und beides gehört zusammen
ich möchte übrigens deutlich machen dass
aus meiner sicht auch nur eines wichtig
ist es wurde vorher der name frank meyer
erwähnt wir deutschen können derzeit
ruhig über die entwicklung diskutieren
weil wir unter nato schutzschirm leben
weil wir die amerikaner haben die uns
schützen das muss man ganz klar sagen
ansonsten würde russland heute schon
mehr destabilisieren im nato gebiet wenn
nicht der schutzschirm da wäre und ich
habe sorge wie das land mittelfristig
ausschaut deswegen plädiere
europapolitiker dafür dass europa
endlich einen eigenen verteidigung
spiler aufbauen muss wir müssen in der
lage sein uns eigenständig zu schützen
natürlich in napoli will die nato nicht
ersetzen aber ich will dass wir auch im
zweifel und eigenständig schützen können
und das immer beim
raketenabwehrschild des europa dringend
braucht dann sind wir beim cyber defense
wo europa dringend europäische
strukturen braucht um sich im internet
zu schützen wir sind dort derzeit nackt
das muss man sich bewusst machen wir
sind dort nicht geschützt ohne
amerikanische unterstützung und das kann
auf dauer so nicht bleiben aber dafür
auch um all diese rüstungskäufe zu
finanzieren muss es ja der wirtschaft
gut gehen hervor was bedeutet das
eigentlich wir jetzt so viel mehr geld
für waffen für rüstung ausgeben
die bundesregierung hat die 100
milliarden euro für ein sondervermögen
für die bundeswehr bereit gestellt
also wenn jemand sich so etwas leisten
kann sicherlich deutschland denn wenn
man jetzt mal vergleicht das sind fast
500 milliarden euro von der
bundesregierung in den jahren 2020 20 1
man sich zur bekämpfung der pandemie
bereitgestellt worden
und ich denke man muss es immer auch
hier herr weber hat es angesprochen wir
haben im letzten 10 15 jahren zu häufig
den fehler gemacht auf kurzfristige
wirtschaftliche profite zuschauer so
sagen wir wollen möglichst billiges gas
aus russland haben dann kommen lasst uns
die erneuerbaren energien mal
verschieben und den ausbau von
photovoltaik und windkraft und ich
glaube diesen fehler dieses kurzfristige
denken das ist der fehler dass wir uns
in diese abhängigkeit begeben haben
wirtschaftlich glaube ich muss jetzt
auch ein richtungswechsel geschehen man
kann auch nicht sagen wir investieren
jetzt nur in verteidigung sondern muss
gleichzeitig eben auch in klimaschutz
und erneuerbaren investieren denn nur so
kommt man ja aus der abhängigkeit von
russland und von anderen
energielieferanten große frage wenn wir
100 milliarden in den klimaschutz
investieren ist das sozusagen ja auch
eine investition in sicherheit genau das
nicht nur in sicherheit sondern es ist
eben auch wirtschaftlich sinnvoll ja und
wir sehen ja wir haben vielleicht in den
jahren 2010 bis 2020 geld gespart weil
wir billiges russisches gas gekauft
haben aber jetzt zahlen wir ein
vielfaches auch des wirtschaftlichen
preises also gute investition in
sicherheit ist letztlich langfristig
auch eine gute investition wirtschaft
nicht aber auch das fordert dann geduld
es gibt eine meldung von asp die usa
wollen jegliche neue investitionen in
russland verbieten frau weiß band wie
sehr
setzen sie auf die usa da auch und wie
finden sie das das verhalten der usa im
vergleich auch zu deutschland vielleicht
austreten
die usa mit am entschlossensten auf und
im zusammenhang mit den usa habe ich
zwei radikal positive entwicklungen des
westens generell gesehen erst
dadurch dass die us-geheimdienste
noch vor dem einmarsch in die ukraine
beschlossen haben alle ihre
informationen zu teilen und zu sagen wir
wissen dass russland in die ukraine
einmarschieren wird sie haben dadurch
viel riskiert aber es war wie ein
schutzschirm gegen russische
desinformation wenn als es dann passiert
ist war das narrativ gesetzt und dadurch
waren wir sicher vor so einer
chaotischen blindheit die russland bei
uns sonst gerne erzeugt zweitens dass
der westen generell so geschlossen
tatsächlich mit diesen harten sanktionen
gegen die zentralbank unter anderem
direkt raus gekommen ist war ein
psychologischer effekt denn ich glaube
die sanktionen wirken nicht nur auf der
wirtschaftlichen ebene sie wirken auch
auf der psychologischen ebene je stärker
je geeint hat die demokratischen systeme
sich positionieren hast du weniger
rechner putin damit für ihn ist der
westen schwach blick agent und wenn wir
geschlossen vorausgehen wenn wir den
takt bestimmen dann wird er in seinem
handeln und sicher wieder um und dann
ist er in die reaktion gezwungen und das
ist ein vorteil nur ich sehe dass diese
unterstützung durch die usa natürlich
zeitlich begrenzt ist wir haben jetzt 22
mid term elections das heißt der
präsident wird seine mehrheit
wahrscheinlich verlieren und das
bedeutet wir können von den usa immer
weniger erwarten wir haben dort eine
startende stimme der christen
national ist also eine prognostische
bewegung die die dort stark die dort an
die macht kommen könnte die sich mit
russland und anderen
rechtspopulistischen triften europas
verbündet und das wäre ein sehr sehr
schlechtes noch nicht offensichtlich
weshalb man auch mal dann müssen wir ja
dafür sprechen würde das europa und
deutschland da sozusagen stärker
in die pflicht genommen wird oder tun
ich werde ich werde da nicht
widersprechen denn tatsächlich ist es
einfach so dass unser wohlstand darauf
basiert dass wir ganz ganz viele dinge
ausgepreist haben wir haben die wahren
kosten unserer produkt unserer
wirtschaft unserer industrie versteckt
verschoben an zukünftige generationen
sollen die sich darum kümmern wenn wir
jetzt nicht radikal umdenken und unsere
wirtschaft so aufbauen dass sie auch
dann wirtschaftlich funktioniert wenn
wir die wahren kosten tatsächlich
bezahlen mit den produkten mit der
arbeitskraft wenn wir die umweltkosten
bezahlen damit die sicherheitskosten
mitbezahlen
wenn wir in eine welt die nicht mehr
bewohnbar ist und insofern ist es auch
genau die zeitenwende von der wir
irgendwie alle sprechen und der
bundeskanzler scholz am 27 februar
sprach morgen wird es eine befragung der
bundesregierung und eine aktuelle stunde
geben zum zum angriff auf butter auf
antrag der ampelkoalition wenn man jetzt
noch mal zurück schaut unsere frage der
sendung ist ja auch deutschland genug
tut frau darf der bundespräsident
steinmeier hat auch gestern gesagt das
ist eine bittere bilanz wir haben das
falsch eingeschätzt alles mit mit dieser
mit diesem rückblick auch wie viel mehr
müsste deutschland dann jetzt eigentlich
tun
also ich glaube wenn man das ganz
konkret auf butscher bezieht dann gibt
es nicht das eine was wir jetzt mehr tun
können sondern wir können natürlich
sozusagen noch mal die sanktionen
verschärfen das wird ja auch kommen aber
es geht nicht darum dass wir sozusagen
hiergegen etwas ganz konkretes tun
können wir können nur unser bestes tun
herr weber hat gesagt wir können mehr
wir können schneller waffen liefern bei
deutschland heißt das vor allem ein
werden ja nicht umsonst 100 milliarden
sondervermögen aufnehmen müssen wir
müssen sie vor allen dingen kaufen denn
schon die bundeswehr hat ja gar nicht
sozusagen das gerät das sie weiter geben
könnte und wir können sozusagen an die
sanktionen arbeiten wir können uns im
bereich der flüchtlinge engagieren und
dafür sorgen dass menschen hier bei uns
schutz finden all das können wir tun
letzten endes geht es aber glaube ich
tatsächlich jetzt schon darum und das
will momentan niemand hören ich kann das
auch gut verstehen die zukünftige
ordnung voraus zu planen denn irgendwann
ja und die europäische ordnung
irgendwann wird dieser krieg auf die
eine oder andere art zu ende gehen und
was werden wir dann eigentlich errichten
das eine ist wichtig zu sagen die
ukraine gehört in die eu aber natürlich
gehört die ukraine in die eu das scheint
mir vollkommen klar zu sein für
wichtiger scheint für mich aber zu sein
dass wir jetzt in diesem prozess der
kontrollierten entflechtung einsteigen
wir haben also wir haben wir jetzt viel
darüber geredet im grunde genommen haben
wir auf kosten der sicherheit und in
abhängigkeit beispielsweise von russland
und den anderen bereichen beispielsweise
von china begeben jetzt geht es darum
diese aber russland als partner
einzubinden und
partner begegnen sich auf augenhöhe wenn
wir aber für die schlechten beziehung
eingehen in denen wir eben nicht auf
augenhöhe sind sondern letzten ende
sozusagen am ausgestreckten arm
verhungern weil wir uns in eine
situation gebracht damit der wehr
erpressbar sind dann reden wir nicht
mehr über partnerschaften man hat das
lange getan weil man gar nicht wahrhaben
wollte dass man in eine situation kommen
könnte in der es wieder zum konflikt
kommt in der sinn für jetzt aber und das
heißt jetzt muss es darum gehen diese
extrem asymmetrischen verflechtungen
tatsächlich zurückzubauen das heißt
wieder redundanzen aufzubauen das heißt
innerhalb der politischen lager zu
verflechten jenseits der politischen
lager zu des integrieren das heißt zu
entflechten und gleich würde ich auch
terrassen dass das nicht komplett in
alle bereiche überstrahlt also die
entscheidung der usa keinerlei
investitionen mehr an russland das halte
ich zum beispiel für gefährlich denn wir
brauchen ein gewisses ausmaß an
verflechtung so lange ist ein gewisse
symmetrie aufweist weber wie würden sie
das sehen wie müsste man sozusagen auch
mit dem eingeständnis dass die dass es
fehleinschätzungen und gabeln und sein
verhältnis zu russland irgendwie musste
man was müsste deutschland da jetzt tun
die müsste deutschland da jetzt
vorangehen die bundeskanzlerin steht ja
zum beispiel weiter zu ehren und zu
ihrer entscheidung mit dem nato-gipfel
2008 in bukarest als klar war wann man
will eben nicht dass die ukraine in die
nato kommt wie würden sie das im
nachhinein sehen
wir zunächst die konkrete entscheidung
2008 in bukarest ist für mich der beste
beweis dafür dass die nato gegenüber
russland nie ein aggressives verhalten
an den tag gelegt hat die ganze
propaganda von putin wir würden uns
gegen seinen willen ausweiten und seine
sicherheitsinteressen nicht respekt ist
gerade mit angela merkels entscheidung
damals 2008 bewiesen dass das einfach
ein lüge ist weil wir eben nicht die
ukraine aufgenommen haben egal wie würde
es im rückblick sieht aber das zerstört
zumindest die propaganda argumentation
putins für mich ist jetzt die zentrale
fragestellung wir deutschen wir europäer
leben vom export wir leben von der
tatsache dass unsere produkte in die
welt verkaufen dürfen und wird wenn wir
jetzt den weg gehen dass wir die
integrieren wenn wir jetzt den weg gehen
dass wir sozusagen souveränität wieder
aufbauen dann werden auch andere
regionen der welt sagen naja warum
kaufen wird an die europäischen produkte
das heißt es wird für unser ganzer
schwierige entwicklung und deswegen war
ich ein stück weit davor dass wir nur
diese richtung gehen natürlich wollen
wir mehr unabhängigkeit da bin ja dabei
aber ich werde vor allem für einen
offensiven ansatz ich möchte dass wir
die freie welt die wir haben in auf
globaler ebene es sind 60 prozent des
weltwirtschafts produktes gehören zu den
freien ländern zu den demokratien die
müssen jetzt sich zusammenschließen wir
wollten wir bräuchten eine wto für die
freie welt handelsverträge und dann muss
ich ihnen sagen bin ich erschüttert das
ist uns nicht mal gelingt im bundestag
einen handelsvertrag mit kanada
abzustimmen wo die grünen gegen zeta
stimmung gemacht haben das ist jetzt
auch noch mal ändern dass wir haben dort
eine stärken das müssten wir eigentlich
jetzt verstärkt angehen marcus so
abschließen wir müssen jetzt mit den
ländern die sich demokratien nennen
sicher nicht alle sowohl entwickelt wie
wir europäer aber dort wo wir freie
medien kennt dort wo man demokratie
kennt die müssten sich jetzt zusammen
schließen müssten sagen wir gehen den
weg weiter der partnerschaft wir glauben
an das miteinander wir glauben an die
multipolare welt an die regelbasierte
welt und wenn china eben nicht mitmachen
will bei diesem spiel dann wird es
langfristig auch wirtschaftlich da
schwächer ist während der er für uns
auch nicht einhalten sind würde das
funktionieren dass wir sagen wir handeln
nur noch mit denen die uns genehm sind
mein herr beck ist gerade nach katar
gefahren nein das wirklich funktionieren
man kann über russland und china sagen
was man will und das ist sicherlich
richtig das sind autokratische regime
die eben nicht die verlässlichkeit haben
einen liberalen demokratien aber wir
sind noch mal stärker auf china
angewiesen nicht nur wegen
handelsverflechtungen sondern weil china
einen großen teil der seltenen erden der
rohstoffe weltweit kontrolliert und der
richtige weg ist nichts zu sagen wir
machen jetzt nur noch was im westen und
dann bekommt man letztlich in einen
neuen kalten krieg sondern die frage die
in letzten nächsten 20 jahren
entscheiden wird sein wird wie können
wir global die integration gelingen und
vor allem die standards setzen und
standards geht's nach ethischen
standards dem menschenrechtsstandards
sicherheit stand als das ist die frage
wer sitzt diese standards und da müssen
gerade wird deutschen unser auch unser
wirtschaftsmodell ändern also griff
werteorientierte außenwirtschaftspolitik
die sich nachhaltig das muss letztlich
oben auf der agenda stehen und das jetzt
mal auch mal aus der perspektive chinas
gesprochen das brauchen die genauso wie
wir also ich glaube dürfen nicht
polarisieren sondern wir müssen
letztlich die globalisierung klüger
gestalten ok klüger gestalten ich würde
ganz gerne frau weiß man ganz am schluss
noch eben eine frage stellen frau weiß
man gibt es etwas was ihn im moment doch
noch irgendwie hoffnung gibt
die solidarität der menschen in
deutschland nicht nur der menschen in
deutschland der menschen weltweit ich
sehe die resilienz der ukraine erinnern
und ich weiß dass es gefährlich wirkt im
moment das aufsteigen des
internationalen autoritarismus aber ich
sehe auch dass langsam die demokratie
wieder erwacht und wieder zu sich findet
und wieder lernt was man eigentlich
daran hat in einem freien land zu leben
und vielleicht ist es dieser kampfgeist
der uns durch die nächste zeit hilft
dann danke ich ihnen ganz herzlich für
dieses schlusswort vielen dank frau weiß
band herr weber hervor und forderten hof
das war unsere phoenix runde heute auf
morgen schauen wir noch mal auf dieses
thema fragen noch mal etwas genauer
welche richtung die deutsche
außenpolitik denn in zukunft nehmen soll
jetzt gibt es aber erstmal phoenix der
tag mit meinem kollegen stephan kulle
bis dann
[Musik]